les supporters fait la victoire devant
sa résidence
le président ghanéen nana akufo addo a
été réélu mercredi face à son rival
politique historique john mahama qu'il
affrontait pour la troisième fois à
l'issue d'un scrutin extrêmement serré
le leader du nouveau parti patriotique
remporte 51 59 % des suffrages contre
47,36 pour son rival john mahama une
élection sous extrême tension cinq
personnes ont été tuées dans des
violences électorales depuis lundi selon
la police le président nouvellement élu
lui appelle à l'unité les deux parties
le npp et le ndc doivent travailler
ensemble en particulier au parlement
pour le bien du pays
le temps est venu pour chacun d'entre
nous indépendamment de nos affiliation
politique de s'unir de se donner la main
de se tenir côte à côte et de travailler
dur pour placer le ghana là où ils
méritent d'être john mahama qui a
remporté la majorité parlementaire lors
des législatives avait mis en garde nana
akufo addo contre toute tentative de
voler le scrutin vous ne pouvez pas
utiliser l'armé pour essayer de
renverser certains des résultats obtenus
dans les circonscriptions que nous avons
gagné nous résisterons à toute tentative
de subvertir la volonté du peuple
ghanéen
les partisans du président élu e n'ont
aucun doute sur sa victoire
qu'ils le veuillent ou non nana a gagné
c'est fini le mdc sont des menteurs nous
n'aimons plus john mahama nous voulons
la paix au ghana nous voulons nana akufo
addo
pour ce nouveau mandat le président aura
pour principale mission de s'attaquer au
chômage des jeunes qui a été l'un des
enjeux au coeur de cette campagne
plus de la moitié des électeurs ayant
moins de 35 ans autre objectif pour le
président et pas des moindres relancer
la croissance d'un pays durement
impactée par la crise du coronavirus